as nuclear for Lowndes over the Pacific
continues the federal government has
declared Los Angeles uninhabitable the
base is four square miles all under NATO
command to be sure lieutenant we're
highly classified you are gonna be the
first man on Titan it's just an honor to
have been selected sir not gonna let you
down our resources have been depleted in
ten years half the world's population
will starve today after planet will be
uninhabitable but there is one place
gives us hope the largest moon of Saturn
what if Titan could become our home you
will become enhanced humans most of you
will fail
some people will vote during the
training your docking forced evolution
I'm talking survival of the species I've
studied your work I know what we're
doing here it's bigger than all of us
this is a lot of same some of us began
to hate me for a while
I never thought I'd see something like
this he's changing
this is a space research it's criminal
becoming violent I want to finish I can
see everything there is something alive
inside of him he's a soldier
there's no going back I mean I thought I
would have got this far
how could possibly what
if we can't control it
all of us have dead
[Music]